in the lobby of financial peace Plaza it
is Mike and Jeanette how are you doing
great welcome welcome and where do you
guys live we're in Biloxi Mississippi
right now at Keith's the Air Force Base
and as cold as it is in Nashville today
you're wishing you were there not much
but a little bit oh my goodness welcome
to financial peace Plaza and the
Martha's place and I assume you guys are
here to do your debt-free scream yes
there we are that is fun and you're the
first one for 2014 live on the air all
right I love it
so how much have you paid off we paid
off one hundred and seventy seven
thousand three hundred ninety one and
twenty-six cents Wow excellent and how
long did that take you took four years
oh man that's interesting cool making
what kind of money we started at about
82 and we're about at 92 now excellent
so you paid off like 40 grand a year
yeah could you sell stuff
not much no we just kind of busted it no
this was a house or a big car or
anything like that
I mean you just you've been I'm a beans
and rice for four freaking years yeah
absolutely
it's like Anna Miller military
discipline right there so man that's
incredible and you are in the military
right sir and which branch do you serve
currently in the Air Force okay
excellent well thank you for your
service we appreciate it have you lived
in Biloxi the whole time
no we started my Fort Drum New York then
Fort Dix McGuire up in New Jersey then
San Antonio Texas and now in Biloxi okay
that's a normal course I guess that's
right very cool very cool so what made
you four years ago decided to get out of
debt I became a physician assistant and
joined the military and we were still
living paycheck to paycheck and it was a
little frustrating actually one of the
military chaplains played when your
introduction is the financial piece and
we got hooked too right Lynn in there oh
cool so were you there when that was
played Jeannette or did he come home all
excited and go we're going to do this
crazy stuff together okay together okay
cool so nobody had to talk anybody into
it or anything like that she's the saver
it is easy it's easy for her she's like
oh you grab brains that's cool what'd
you do with my husband yeah
my pockets got fixed that's fun very
cool so what was the hardest thing you
did in the last four years to get out of
debt I think the hardest thing was just
sticking with it I mean there was times
when it was easy and we were on a roll
and then there was some months it was
just we were tired of it what was the
hardest month where you just wanted to
give up
May 2013 oh [ __ ] that you knew what
happened in May we got the blood seen
all my buddies we catch a nice big fish
and uh I had a dinghy a little I rented
a dinghy every weekend and I find I did
I fell off the wagon I broke down and I
spent $1,700 on an old floating tub that
I'm still fishing out of so oh my gosh
he fell off the wagon and bought a boat
yeah so what happened when he did that
Janette we had some good discussions
that's great what was easier than you
thought it was going to be you watch
those that tape the first time and then
you went through the course obviously as
a part of our military program and and
you're looking at it all and you go that
this is going to be really tough and
what was easier than you thought I
wouldn't say probably the budget for me
because I was the more the free spirit
in the spender and once we were on board
the communication our marriage opened up
and with everything had just you know it
infiltrated all of our lives but you
know every aspect of her life and
everything got better okay so you you
kind of looking at it from the outside
outside looking in you thought this
budget thing is going to be a total pain
in the button it turned out to not be
yeah no idea how to do one really I mean
yeah you know I don't how got through
life without doing that but it made our
life so much easier
very cool what kind of debt was the
hundred and seventy seven thousand oh
man you name it the American Dream right
so cars student loans credit cards a
little bit everything was the dumbest
thing you bought on debt probably a new
car I I got a little depressed right
before my deployment Afghanistan and I
was turning 30 and I didn't have
anything to show for it yet and I bought
Lexus pretty dumbly and as soon as uh we
went you know went through your class I
was immediately sold right we got
started okay what did that bring uh well
we broke even on it okay yeah all right
so you got out of that part I did yeah
very very cool well you guys are awesome
congratulations that's huge most people
can't stick with anything for minutes
you stuck with it for years is there
that's called attention span that's
called setting a goal and hitting it
you're pretty incredible and you did
that for come a physician's assistant
too you know how to set long-range goals
to sacrifice to win you know to live
like no one else so later you can live
like no one else and you've been doing
it a long time I can tell you now
sitting 25 years the other side of where
you're standing to bei that it works and
you've just begun the journey of winning
well you've changed motivation listen to
you every day even while deployed and I
was gonna mark this day down we're gonna
do this so we're gonna come here and do
this debt scream you know that scream
here right here in person yes sir I'm
glad you're here I'm glad for that
milestone that's very cool all right
Mike and Jeanette from mill up from UM
from the military in Biloxi Mississippi
a hundred and seventy seven thousand
dollars paid off in four years making 82
to 92 thousand dollars now counted down
let's hear a great debt free screen guys
ready three two one
well done you guys very well done
that's fun